ALLIE LV THAT COM ROCKY THANK
YOU JULIAN, I WRITE THIS GO
THE SPONSORS OFRS THRSIS NRSEXTS
RSSEGMRSENT.RS THERSIR PURPOSPUU
THAN JUST SHARING FOOD. .
THEY'RE HERE TO HELP YOU AND
YOUR BUSINESS TO HERE'S HOW.
>> WELCOME TO CISCO LAS VEGAS
MINE AND ANDY BIROL AGAIN ON
THE CULINARY SPECIALIST HERE
CISCO IS THE LARGEST FOOD
DISTRIBUTOR IN THE WORLD
PROVIDING BUSINESSES WITH
PRODUCTS AND OPERATING
SOLUTIONS FOR THEIR BUSINESSES
ARE PURPOSES CONNECTING THE
WORLD TO SHARE FOOD AND CARE
FOR ONE ANOTHER FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOUR RESTAURANT OUT THERE THAT
NEEDS ANY OF THESE PRODUCTS.
WHAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE FOR
YOU. THE GREAT THING ABOUT OUR
CUTTING FOR THE REASONS THAT
WE JUST DON'T HAVE ONE PRODUCT
THAT GOES TO ONE CUSTOMER ARE
OUR PRODUCTS CAN ACTUALLY BE
UTILIZED ACROSS THE BOARD FOR
EXAMPLE THESE PULLED OUT OVER
HERE YOU CAN UTILIZE THEM IN
TACOS AND PASTA ANYTHING LIKE
THAT WITH THE CAULIFLOWER
TORTILLAS ALSO THE PULLED
CHICKEN YOU CAN UTILIZE IN A
IN A WHOLE W CH WICKE WN SANDWI
TACOS IN AND TO ENSURE LOT OF
INTO A BARBECUE CHICKEN
SANDWICH SO REALLY IT GOES
WITH ALL GENRES AND OUR LAST
BUT NOT LEAST WE AN AMAZING
CARMEL APPLE CHEESECAKE THAT
REALLY COULD JUST GO EVERY
WAY. IN ADDITIADON TO OUR
CUTTING A SOLUTION WE HAVE
IN-HOUSE BUSINESS REVIEWS AN
OFF-SITE BUSINESS IN HOUSE,
THE PREVIOUS WE REALLY BRING
THE PEOPLE AND WE CAN MAKE
MENUS FOR THAT WILL COOK THE
FOOD UP FOR TEST OUT PRODUCTS
MAYBE DO A CUTTING OF YOU KNOW
MAYBE 5 OR 6 DIFFERENT TYPES
OF BACON SO THEY CHOOSE AND
PAY WHAT THEY LIKE. OFF SITE
WE CAN GO IN SEEN PROBLEMS
THAT ARE IN THEIR RESTAURANTS RA
AND HELP THEM THINGS SO REALLY
WE'RE RESOURCE THAT I DON'T
TH
INK
ANY
OTHE
R FOOD
DISTRIBUTOR HAT AND REALLY
BUSINESS REVIEWS ARE  AFOR NEW
OR POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS.
SOMEONE WANTS TO BE A
POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS REALLY
JUST NEED TO YOU KNOW CALL
WILL SEND OUT A WILL SIT DOWN
HAVE  A   MEETING AND THEN WE'
TOSS TO PAPERWORK, YOU KNOW
CISCO HAS MANY OF ITS OWN
BRANDED ITEMS WE HAVE OVER 20
DIFFERENT BRANDS FROM DAIRY TO
PRODUCE WE EVEN HAVE SOMETHING
CALLED SUPPLIES ON THE FLY
WERE ON YOU CAN GET EQUIPMENT,
YOU KNOW FOR YOUR RESTAURANT
IF YOU'RE OPENING SOMETHING
YOU KNOW WE WE CAN SUPPORT YOU
ACROSS THE BOARD AND YOU KNOW
REALLY SOMETIMES THE BRANDING
IS EXACTLY LIKE
>> FOR INSTANCE, A CATCH-UP
VERSUS A CATCH UP WHERE
EXACTLY THE SAME BUT WE CAN
HELP YOU OUT NOW A VEGAS
RESTAURANTS ARE OPENING BACK
UP AND WE REALLY WANT TO
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY AND BE
BEHIND THEM. YOU KNOW WHERE
STARTING TO LIVE OR 6 DAYS A
WEEK TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
SMALLER RESTAURANTS, WE HAVE
HAVE A LOT OF SPACE AND YOU
KNOW WE JUST REALLY WANT TO
GET BEHIND PEOPLE AND MAKE BIG
A STRONG AGAIN.
>> THANKS TO THIS COLD FRONT
FOODS FOR SPONSORING THE
SEGMENT FOR MORE INFORMATION